hey everyone this is ravi from simply
learn
welcome to this youtube marketing full
course video for 2021.
in this full course video we will be
covering the topics like
how can you set up a youtube channel how
youtube ads work
it different types some video ideas that
your brand can use and how you can
increase
youtube subscribers for this video we
have our experts
rob and rahul taking us through all the
topics so without further ado
let's get started by talking about how
you can create a youtube channel
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
[Music]
youtube how-tos building a presence on
youtube
is like fine-tuning the engine of a car
to get maximum performance in youtube
terms
this means maximum views and maximum
subscribers to your youtube channel
the instruments you have for this are
the video itself
how you optimize it in youtube and the
quality of the youtube channel you
create
to promote your youtube presence
if you do get maximum performance out of
your youtube presence
youtube will reward you by giving you
the opportunity to monetize your youtube
videos
through the youtube advertising
platforms
by the end of this lesson you will know
how to use the new youtube studio beta
how to upload and optimize a youtube
video
how to create and optimize a youtube
channel
how to create a playlist on your youtube
channel
how to make a great video and how to
monetize your youtube presence
youtube has just launched the new
youtube studio beta
most of the youtube features like
uploading and optimizing your videos
have been brought into the new youtube
studio beta
some of the features like creating your
youtube channel
still need to be accessed through the
old version of youtube studio
soon these features will be brought into
the new version
which will make the old version obsolete
when you are successful in youtube in
views and subscribers
youtube will give you the opportunity to
monetize
your youtube presence
upload video on desktop
upload a video on youtube you can do
that on the desktop
and you can also do that on the mobile
let's have a look at the desktop version
of uploading your video
so what you do is you go to the
youtube.com
homepage and as long as you're logged
into your google account
you see your little login account info
here
you will then see on the left a little
camera with a plus sign
and that's where you can upload a video
click on that
you can then upload your video or you
can go live streaming
so let's click on upload video and that
takes you to this screen
where you can select the file to upload
or you can drag and drop the video
file you can immediately add the
settings for published
public unlisted private or you can
schedule the video
you can also import videos from your
google photos drive
you can start live streaming from here
as well and there is a new feature
which is called premiere this is where
you can schedule a video and invite your
followers
to watch the video together with you and
when the schedule date
is there the video goes public on
youtube and you can watch it together on
the premiere screen
so what i'm going to do is to select the
file to upload
i just click on the finder and then i
can drag the video file
here in the box and while it is
uploading
i can enter basic info of the video in
this case i will call it
flower garden in malaysia you can then
give a description
you can set tags so when the processing
of the video is complete
you can pick your thumbnail and then you
click publish
and you will see that the video is live
on youtube
so let's select set the thumbnail you
can see that the processing is done
and here i click to publish the video
is now live so if i click here on the
link
it will actually take me to the video
and there is my video on youtube
the flower garden in malaysia
upload video on mobile to
upload the video through your mobile you
have to use the youtube mobile app
once you start a mobile app you will see
at the top the little video icon
when i click on that icon there are
various options you can choose from
i can click record if i want to create a
video that i want to upload
i can click on go live that takes me
straight into the live streaming of my
video
or i can select a video from the video
library on my phone
so for this demo i will click on select
the video
and then i can select the video that i
want to upload there are some basic
editing functions i have on the video
i'll show that in a later demo and if i
want to select this video
i click on next and as we saw with the
desktop demo i can add the name
and the description of the video and i
can then upload the video on youtube
the video is now uploaded so once the
video is ready
you will see it in the list of the
videos and then
obviously you can go into the edit mode
to add more details in the title
or in the description and optimize your
video
so now you see that the video is
uploaded to my list of videos on youtube
and you can also see it's just placed
above the video that i just
uploaded through the desktop version of
youtube
youtube studio beta youtube has come up
with a new version of the interface
to manage your videos on youtube it's
called youtube studio beta
not all the features have moved to the
new version
for those features that haven't migrated
yet youtube will
direct you to the old version of the
interface or
if you prefer the old interface youtube
will still give you the option to switch
back to
it but like they do with migrations to
new interfaces
after a few months they will switch the
option to move back off
the new interface is very simple to use
let me show you the desktop version of
it
and then i will show you the mobile app
for it
to access youtube creator studio beta
you have to be logged into your google
account
and when you're on the youtube.com
homepage you click on your little photo
here
on the right and then you click on
youtube studio beta
that will take you to the youtube studio
beta dashboard
what you see here at the bottom left is
creator studio classic
so you can still switch back to the
classic format of the creator studio
and again if you want to switch back to
the studio beta
you click here on creator studio beta to
go back to the new interface
there are still a few features like
creating playlists
translations transcriptions that sit in
the old version
when you select those you will go back
to creator studio classic
so what's there to see on the dashboard
first of all you have your latest video
that you uploaded with some basic
information
you can go to the video analytics of
this particular video
and the see comments you also get a list
of your channel analytics highlights it
gives you a link to your channel
analytics
and your top videos of the last two
hours
and then here you see content that
youtube presents
like youtube news and information about
creator insider
here they give you additional videos
where you can learn about how to use
youtube
it will also show you some ideas on how
to improve your channel
or in this case help navigating the new
interface
here on the left you have your main menu
you can go into your videos analytics
check out the comments go to the
transcriptions of your videos
and other features and then down here
you have your settings
and link back to the creator studio
classic
so if we click here on videos you have a
list of
all the videos that you have uploaded on
youtube
it's much friendlier and much better
accessible
than in the old creator studio classic
so here you see the two videos that
we've just uploaded
and then here you see what is the
visibility of the video
and the date that you published it
you'll also see how many views how many
comments and how many likes or dislikes
a really good new feature here is the
inline editing as we call this
if i want to quickly change the title or
the description of this video
i don't have to open the video and click
on edit
i can actually click it here i can
actually change it here
in line so there's a few things i can do
in line
edit the title and the description get a
link
promote for advertising download or
delete the video
so if i say edit title and description
and add in
consoles and then i'm here i'm just
clicking
and then i'm just clicking save and you
see it will automatically change the
title
so this is a very easy and convenient
new feature
i can click here and see the video
directly on youtube as well
and here you see the analytics so when
you click on analytics
it takes you to the general overview of
the analytics
where you can see what's the activity
and what's the views that we got in our
channel
what are the top videos that people are
watching what is the real time activity
happening on your videos
and then you can see here about the
viewers
the interest of the viewers the built-in
audience and how to earn revenue
so we'll get back into the analytics
later but at least here you have an idea
of what you can get from the analytics
you can then check out the comments that
you had on the various videos
you can look at the transcription files
that you had for your videos
and which ones have been published and
then it takes you to your other features
as well
in the settings you can set things like
the currency that you're using
what your default experience is for the
classic or for the new youtube studio
beta
you can have your channel settings like
the name of your channel
the keywords for your channel and the
country for your channel
you can check on your community you can
add filters
you can look at the moderators and the
proofed users that you can add
and you can look at other settings like
your advanced channel settings or
channel branding
but you will access these through the
creator studio classic
so this gives you a short overview of
the creator studio beta
using youtube studio on a mobile
to access youtube studio on your mobile
you have to download the mobile app
and then when you open the mobile app
you could almost like a similar
experience as on the desktop
it starts with your dashboard this gives
you an
overview of your analytics of the last
28 days
the last videos that you uploaded the
last comments that you received
and the total number of subscribers you
have to your channel
to access the menu you tap on the
hamburger button on the top left
and this gives you a similar list of
options that you have on the desktop
version
you can go to your videos you can check
your playlist
check the comments go to your analytics
and change your youtube settings
when i click on videos it gives you a
list of all the videos that you uploaded
for each video you see the number of
views the number of comments
the number of likes the number of
dislikes
you can sort the videos by most recent
most viewed and you can look at all the
videos
you can filter by draft by public
unlisted
and private videos the view from your
mobile
is very easy and it's simple to browse
through all the videos that you've
uploaded on your mobile
you can look at your playlist and make
some changes to your playlist
and then you can also check the comments
on the videos
if you click on analytics you get more
detailed stats about your videos
you can see your overview any revenue
that you would have made
you can look at analytics for your
playlist and it also gives you analytics
of
any interactive content that you have
used in your videos
like click or cards let's go back to the
dashboard to complete this demo
this gives you an idea of what you can
manage
through the youtube studio app
editing a video on youtube now that your
video is uploaded on youtube
there are two things that you may want
to do first
you may want to edit the video like
trimming the beginning or the end
or adding some special effects to the
video and you definitely have to
optimize the video for search on both
youtube and google
so let's have a look at both of these
areas and to start with editing the
video
let's take for instance this video here
a video blog that i did
a little while ago if i click on the
video
it takes me to the area where i can add
the information to optimize the video
and i'll come back to that later but
here you can click on editor
and this takes me to a full screen video
editing mode
it's a very basic video editing so it
doesn't give you all the functionality
like for instance imovie or adobe
premiere
but it does the thing for you if you
want to make some quick changes to the
video
you can trim the video you can add music
or play with the sound of the video
you can add an end screen to the video
and you could blur
faces for instance on the video these
are basic
functions but they work really well
let's have a look first at the sound
if i click here on audio and i open the
audio library that youtube has
it gives you a full library of
royalty-free music tracks that you can
add to your video
so for instance i can select hear the
noise
i can add that to my video when it's too
loud
you have a slider where you can say
favorite to the original audio
so now you hear my voice in the
background in today's video blog let's
go back now and close this
you can also add an end screen to the
video and there are a number of
templates you can choose from an end
screen will show
during the last 20 seconds of the video
you can show a playlist or a subscribe
button
or you can have reference to two
different videos or
two videos or playlists so different
formats that you can choose from
let's pick the two video template when i
click on apply
then here you would see how that will
show in the last 20 seconds of the video
when i play the video you see that i
haven't added any video but this is how
it would show
as an end screen in your video and then
you can add
blur to a video as well you can blur
faces
or you can blur specific areas in your
video
this is all i will be showing you on
editing your video
as i said before it's a basic video
editor
but if you want to do some quick editing
on your video before you publish it
then this is a really good tool to do
just that
optimizing a video in youtube studio
so the next thing you want to do is to
optimize your video for youtube search
and for google search
so how do you go about it when you
select a video
let's take this one epic fail how to
ruin your life on an easyjet flight
you click on the video and that takes
you to the basic optimization screen
there are a few things that are
important here first of
all the title this title epic fail
how to ruin your life on an easyjet
flight is an interesting title
it tells people there's something
happening here
it's very important to use a word like
epic fail
people like seeing videos with epic
fails so remember
title is extremely important there are
two reasons why people decide to watch a
video on youtube
number one is the title number two is
the thumbnail
and that's the next thing you want to
optimize youtube will pick a few
thumbnails
based on your video but you can also
upload
your own thumbnail the third part is
also important
the description of your video it's
important that the description of the
video is in line
with the title and what the viewer is
going to see
make sure you use keywords that are
relevant to the video
and to your business and here you can
add
tags tags are key for the search
it helps people to find your video based
on the tags that you've set
here you can see the public url of your
video and here you can decide on the
visibility of your video
do you want your video to be public
private or
unlisted unlisted video will be public
but they won't show up in the search
here you can select the playlist that
you want the video to be part of
you can assign a video to the various
playlists that you have on your channel
this is where you can create cards in
the end screen
in the video editing demo we looked at
how you can add
end screens and how you can add video
cards to your video
if you click on it then you see the
editing mode and here are the different
types of cards that you can add
like a video or a playlist or a channel
or you could even create a poll where
you encourage
viewers to participate so you just click
on the create
and then you can pick a video from the
list that shows up
that video will actually show up and
then here you
see where the video card will appear
so if we go to the beginning of the
video and we would click
play then here you see the suggested
video popping up
so you can now save the changes and go
back to the editor
so these are the basic settings for the
optimization of your video
and you can also go to the advanced
settings there's a lot more
that you can add in the advanced
settings
you can add the recording date the
location of the video
and you can also add the license and
right ownership of the video
if you are part of the commercial
network with youtube
you can select the syndication where you
want your videos to show
you can select a category for your video
the language
and the caption certification when there
may be television fcc regulations
regarding closed captions you can also
upload your subtitles and closed
captioning
youtube will actually create subtitles
for you and then you can check that
later
it is not 100 accurate but at least it's
a good starting point for your subtitles
finally you can set things like allowing
comments and
ratings and enabling age restrictions as
well
you can allow people to embed the video
and you can also
tick whether the video contains paid
promotion
like product placement sponsorships or
endorsements
so lots of things that you can set in
the optimization
and when you're happy with it you just
click save
google and youtube will then include all
these settings
in the indexing of the video and the
better you do all this the more likely
your video will show up in the search
so let's go to google and check this
epic fail video
we have a good thumbnail and a good
title
if you go to google and search for epic
fail
easyjet for instance then you see that
the video
immediately shows up here in google and
that's obviously what you want for your
videos
you want them to show up high in the
videos or in the image section of the
search results page
and if you do the same search in youtube
then you would like your video to show
up as well
and you see here immediately it shows up
as the first video
so this is all there is to optimizing
your video
another important part and we briefly
touched on this
are the subtitles and the transcriptions
that you may want to add to your video
first you want to check if youtube
created transcriptions for your video
take this video blog for example if i
select
other futures you see here translation
and transcription
the automated transcription from youtube
has not been brought into the new studio
batter
so i need to go to the old studio of
youtube
so i click here on the old classic
creator studio translation and
transcription
and then here you see the link to the
published transcript file
i haven't put these in this is something
that youtube will do
when it's a video that's worth
transcribing you could copy the text so
you can download it and then use that
for a blog post or for the show notes of
your podcast
you can also add language and you can
set the transcription on published or
draft
very useful features and very important
to make sure that your video is
optimized
creating a youtube channel to create a
youtube channel you have to go
to your youtube homepage and then you
click on the little photo here
that you will see when you locked into
your google account
when you click on the settings it will
take you to the screen
where you will be able to click on the
button see all my channels or create a
new channel
so let's click on this and now you will
see the screen
where you can enter the name of your
channel
and in this case i'm going to call it
riad for russia
i click create and you will then get to
the page where you can start customizing
your channel
if i click on customize channel i see
the blank version
of the youtube channel where you can add
your logo
your channel art and where you can add a
channel description
so let's start with adding a short
channel description
welcome to my youtube channel of riad
for russia
when we're done with that we can add a
logo to do
that you click on the little pencil icon
it will actually
take you to the brand page of your
google account
click on edit and you can upload a photo
click on upload photo
and here we are going to upload this
image
once it has uploaded the photo you can
play a bit with the size of it
you can move it up a bit if you want so
i'm going to move it so i only show the
mosaic
i click done and then my brand page has
been updated with the image
if i now go back to the youtube page and
i do a refresh
you will see that the image has been
added to the youtube page
i can do the same for the channel art
click
on the channel art you need to be aware
that you don't have a lot of space to
play with for your image
so you need to make sure that you have a
horizontal photo
that will show enough of what you want
to cover in the banner
a nice feature is that it will show you
how it will look on the desktop
how it will look on the tv and how it
will look on the mobile
and if you're not happy with it you can
adjust the crop a little
so i can zoom in and then move it up
so at least i see a little bit of the
mountains and the bit of the mosque on
the photo
when i'm happy with it i click select
and then you will see that you have
uploaded the banner
and you are now ready to start
optimizing your youtube channel
checking the youtube channel settings so
the first thing you want to check when
you start
optimizing your channel is your settings
of the channel
you can access the channel settings by
clicking on the little cartwheel on the
top right
click on that and this will take you to
the basic privacy settings
you can keep your videos private
subscriptions private your saved
playlist
private you can customize the layout of
your channel
and you can show the discussion tab so
you can basically switch all these
options on or off
and you can also translate your channel
info
the basic settings you can find on this
little screen
but there are more options in the
account settings and in the advanced
settings
so let's look first at the options in
the account settings
this is where you can look at what
you're going to share on youtube
you can look at your connected apps for
instance in this section
do you want any other apps to connect
with your youtube
you can also set how to connect your tv
to the youtube channel you can connect
your youtube to a particular tv device
and you can look at your billings and
payments and your playback and
performance
this is where you can control your video
experience
you can show annotations and in-video
notifications
you can also set that the captions are
always on
or when that's available show automatic
captions by speech recognition
you can also set the notifications for
your youtube
so you can receive emails about your
activities
if you want updates from youtube or
notifications around channel
subscriptions
and other notifications like recommended
videos
if i go back to the main channel page
and i'm going back into the settings
i can then also go into the advanced
settings for my channel
in the advanced settings i can check the
country that i'm based
i can set keywords for my channels i can
disable
interest-based ads and i can link my
adwords account
i can activate channel recommendations
and display the subscriber account
this is also where you can integrate
your youtube channel with your google
analytics
so look a bit further up here i can see
the branding options that i have so i
can add a watermark to my channel videos
i can also set defaults for uploading my
videos
this can be quite handy if you have
standard text that you want to use for
every video
and i can set some standard tags for
instance this can be helpful when you
upload
lots of videos so the standard defaults
are already set
and then finally here you see the status
and features of your channel
this is where you have all the different
options that you have with your channel
and you can check what the status is the
different elements that are enabled and
elements that you are eligible for and
the elements that you are
ineligible for for example we're not
eligible for monetization because we
haven't signed up for it
and we haven't passed the requirements
for this
so for all these things we can see
whether we have it enabled
whether we are eligible or whether we
are ineligible
and that's all there is to the settings
so let's go back now to the channel
by clicking on the logo and we can then
start looking at the optimization of our
channel
how to optimize your youtube channel to
start customization and optimization of
your youtube channel
you have to go to the standard channel
page
and click customize channel
here you see the structure and elements
of your youtube channel
an important feature is that you can
look at your channel
as yourself as a new visitor
or as a returning visitor
you can set a video at the top of your
youtube channel which will
change whether you're a new visitor or a
returning visitor
but let's first look at the different
elements of your youtube page that you
can change
you can add videos to your channel you
can add playlists to your channel
and you can connect with other channels
you can manage your discussions and you
can put more info
in your about section this is also where
you can link
to your other social media pages these
will show on your channel banner
and you can feature other channels that
you would like to promote on your
youtube channel
so you start with adding some videos to
your channel
click on videos and you see this channel
has no video yet
remember how we uploaded a video in
youtube
by clicking this little plus icon and we
say upload video
we can then select the video that we
want to upload
let's take this short video add some
basic settings
and set some tags
once the video is processed you can then
publish it on your channel page
if you go back to your channel you will
see that the video has been added
so that's how you can upload videos to
your channel
you can then look at playlists here you
can add a playlist to your channel
a playlist is a group of videos around a
particular topic
and then you can feature those playlists
as chapters
in your youtube channel it makes it very
easy to organize your videos
to create a playlist i click on new
playlist
i give it a title marrakesh in this case
additive i click create and then your
playlist has been created
then you need to add videos to your
playlist
if you go back to the video and play it
to get into editing mode
then in the settings of the video i can
say to which playlist
i want to add this video
i select a playlist that i just created
and click
done and i save it and then i have added
a video to my playlist
so if i now go back to my youtube
channel i can click on playlists
and there is my marrakesh playlist and
it currently has one video
i can add channels so i can link to any
other channel i may have
i can manage my discussions and i can
manage my about page in this section as
well
i can activate business inquiries so
people can send me an email through my
channel
i can specify my location and i can add
my social media links who will then show
up in my youtube channel banner
you can also add featured channels for
instance i want to add
the social media examiner youtube
channel i can add that
and i can click done and then it will
show in the featured channels
if i'm happy with the settings i can go
back to my channel
and then you see what we've done to the
channel right now
we've got our first video we have our
featured channel
and we have our playlist
so this is how i can optimize my youtube
channel
one more thing i would like to show you
if i click customize channel
then i can see here the featured content
which will show up on the channel
for either returning visitors or new
visitors
if i click here on feature content and
then i pick for instance the video that
i just
uploaded then this is how it will show
i can add a heading for this content so
for example i can say
feature presentation and i click save
and now you see i have a feature video
for the returning visitors
i can also do this for new visitors i
can create a channel trailer
for instance i pick this video and then
i click save
and that's how it will show for new
visitors so these are the basic things
you need to look at when you want to
optimize your youtube channel
youtube channel views and subscribers
now that we know how to edit and
optimize your videos and your youtube
channel
we will turn our attention to how to
grow views
and subscribers on your channel first
there is your channel optimize your
channel page
write a compelling channel description
use a great channel logo and a banner
and create a channel tagline then there
are your videos
make an awesome channel trailer video
publish
long videos of 10 minutes and more
promote
videos in your end screen add a branded
watermark and add a subscribe button
and end your videos with a strong call
to action
thirdly there is your channel management
reply to
every comment and hard grade contents
and finally promote your channel
embed youtube videos in blog posts and
promote your channel in ebooks webinars
presentations and lead magnets doing
all the things right will certainly help
you in growing views
and subscriptions to your channel
tubebuddy is a great tool
that can help you in growing your video
views and your channel subscriptions
it's a chrome browser extension and it
adds a layer of functionality on top of
your youtube channel
it has features that focus on seo
promotion
and analytics and it also tracks the
video rankings of your videos
but also the videos of your competitors
it's a great tool to find keywords for
your videos
and you can go to your competitor video
and check what tags they have set and
use these as keywords for your videos
it also helps you in publishing videos
on your channel
you can schedule videos to be published
and added to playlists
you can make bulk updates to your videos
including the descriptions
and it also helps you to create
eye-catching thumbnails
factors that make a great video of
course it's not
only the optimization of the video that
makes the video successful
it is also about the video itself done
well
you can use your iphone to make highly
professional
cinema quality videos that are being
watched by millions
as insane a feature movie from film
director steven soderbergh
proved let me give you some tips how to
make great video
think about composition point of view
and lighting first composition is about
how you place
the different elements in the scene put
some thought into this
use the rule of thirds and focus on
people's eyes
i'll explain the rule of thirds shortly
point of view is the angle you are using
of the lens of the camera
in relation to the subject be creative
with this
use a low angle or a high angle and
change these regularly
lighting can make the difference to a
good or a bad video
always be aware of your light source and
also
know that daylight is the best light
source there is
but different times during the day can
give different shadow effects in the
video
for instance noon sunlight creates
unflattering shadows
whereas a cloudy day can produce more
softer lights
using the right equipment is also very
important in
shooting great videos obviously your
phone can fulfill
most of the camera requirements like
shooting video
and recording sounds and it will give
you an acceptable level of quality
make sure the resolution settings on
your phone
are on 4k or 1080 hd
and it's set at 24 30 or 60 frames per
second
avoid zooming avoid backlights and use
both
hands if you want to up the quality to
professional
then you may want to use a high quality
dslr camera
and additional gear like a tripod and a
microphone
the rode lavalier microphone is a great
mic that you can attach to your iphone
and your color it gives excellent
quality sound
and you can overlay that sound over the
sound file of your video
earlier i promised you i was going to
explain the rule of thirds
they are part of the basic rules of
composition
the rule of thirds is a compositional
rule
that suggests dividing the image into
thirds
and placing the subject on one of those
sides
instead of in the center it is one of
the most
important composition techniques used by
professional photographers
but there are others as well for
instance
using balance and symmetry in your video
or apply
leading lines in your video these lines
direct the viewer to a particular
section of the screen
finally as i mentioned before a simple
rule is to focus on the eye it gives a
point of focus
monetizing your youtube channel
there are various ways that you can make
money with youtube
but it depends on how strong your
subscriber base is
and how many views you get on your
channel if you are qualified
then you can participate in google's
adsense program
which means that you can get revenue
from ads being placed before
or during your videos when people watch
them
this works very well and many publishers
on youtube
get a significant revenue stream through
this channel
you can also try to get sponsorships for
your channel
this can take the form of brand or
product sponsorship
for which you will get paid you can also
look into affiliate marketing
with this you can advertise products
from your affiliate partners
on your channel and you would get a
percentage of the sales that comes in
through your channel
and finally if people like your videos
then they may commission you to make
videos for them
as i mentioned before you need to have a
strong
channel to qualify for google's adsense
program
which means you need to have at least 4
000 watch hours in the previous 12 month
and 1 000 subscribers to sign up for
adsense
you need to go to the old version of
creative studio
and click on channel and monetization
you can set the monetization preferences
and which video you want to run the ads
with
if you qualify google will then approve
your request
and you are ready to start earning money
with youtube
here are the key takeaways of this
lesson
youtube has recently launched a new
version
of youtube studio called youtube studio
beta
getting views and subscribers on your
youtube channel
is based on your video the quality and
optimization of your channel
and how you promote your channel
composition lighting and point of view
are important contributors to the
quality of your video
and you can make money with youtube
through advertising
sponsorships and commissioned work
welcome everyone this is rob
sanders and welcome to today's webinar
youtube advertising so today we're going
to talk about youtube advertising so
thanks again
i'm rob sanders and i'm with simply
learn and let's get started
and we're going to do a little role
playing here and let's just say you're
an advertiser and you're not
sure where you want to advertise your
products you have a product that you
want the entire world to see
well if you want to advertise your
products and let's just say you have
some really good video
of your product that you want to get out
there really there's no
other place to look to than one place in
particular
is youtube hence the reason why we're
doing this webinar
because today we're going to talk about
all things
youtube advertising and for those that
don't know
youtube is owned by google and a lot of
what you're going to do
is advertise on youtube via google ads
so
today we're going to talk about youtube
advertising and we're going to focus
somewhat
on google ads so buckle up and
let's get started with why is
advertising on youtube a good idea
so why is it a good idea well if you
haven't been on youtube of late
you should check it out youtube.com and
just take a look at the vastness
of videos that are on youtube now
youtube is a video platform but if it
was a search engine
it'd be the second largest search engine
in the world only behind
its parent company google so it's a very
big platform with a lot of videos and
hence
there's some good search functionality
on youtube so you can look at it as
a search engine there's 1.9 billion and
growing
logged in visitors on a monthly basis so
you have a lot of people that go to
youtube
and watch videos on a daily basis
okay it has local versions in more than
91
countries so if you're an advertiser
who's focusing on a specific market or
you're in a different market with a
different language
you have 91 different options to hone in
on
okay so a little bit more about youtube
here and why
is advertising on youtube a good idea
well most youtube users are on mobile
almost 70 almost three quarters of those
that you
use youtube use it from their mobile
device
which is staggering but not so
staggering considering most people
in the world now have mobile phones or
mobile devices
and most people use their mobile devices
for multiple reasons and
watching videos is one of those reasons
so mobile advertisements receive
viewer attention 83 percent of the time
so what do we mean by that well on
youtube we have the opportunity to
get your ad in front of people who are
watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged in
watching a video on youtube
and you're advertising on that
particular video
well then you're going to get some
attention
and so that attention has to be in the
80 percentile
okay so a lot of people are going to you
know pay
somewhat attention to your ad and it's
no secret video ads have proven to be
more effective and engaging creating
greater impact and and that's just not
on youtube i mean that's
that's on facebook that's on other
platforms like twitter
instagram so video is an engaging
way to communicate it's a lot better
than traditional text that's a lot
better than say a display banner
because it's engaging people are gonna
watch what you have to say
and if they like it they're gonna share
they're gonna comment on it
they're gonna subscribe there's a lot of
things that people can do when it comes
to video advertising
so video helps expand your digital reach
so basically if you are running those
text ads and display ads well
having video kind of adds some more
arsenal
to your advertising portfolio so to
speak so
if you're running just those text ads
and banners that's fine that's great
because you can reach a lot of people
but having video just adds another piece
of the element and because video's so
engaging
you might find that even for yourself if
you're advertising different
types of ads video display or text
you'll find that
you know video does have really really
expansive reach
to a particular audience and the other
thing here
about youtube is youtube helps to find a
relevant audience for your ads
using advanced targeting so just like
anything else that we've talked about
here at simply learn when it comes to
advertising
whether that be facebook or instagram or
google ads
we can really hone in on our audience
here and that's
really important and we'll get to that
later because when you're advertising
you want to make sure your ad is in
front of the right people
and if we're talking about video we're
talking about high engagement
if you have your video in front of a
really relevant audience then
chances of that audience engaging going
to be even greater and then
youtube and video ads themselves provide
it provides a situation that can be
customized to fulfill your marketing
goals
and so what do we mean by that so
basically
youtube allows us some additional
features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to
just get our ad in front of millions of
people well that's not a problem
if our marketing goals get people who
you know we want to convert
well we can customize our marketing goal
towards that as well
so just like on facebook and some of
these other platforms we've talked about
youtube is no different and so we could
set specific marketing goals
uh for our video ads some other good
pointers to to talk about here with
youtube so
with youtube just like on google ads we
can enable
running cost-effective campaigns and
what do i mean by cost-effective well
meaning we can really watch our budget
we can measure how
how much it cost for 1 000 people to
watch our video or we can measure how
much it costs for
somebody to click on our video ad we can
measure
the cost of when somebody clicks on our
video ad and converts how much does that
cost
in us so you can really run cost
effective campaigns even on youtube
and youtube helps determine how
successful your ads with advanced
analytics so
not only do we have analytics on the
youtube side of the house but we also
have
analytics on google ads and so we can
really
hone in and use both platforms to really
figure out exactly how our ads are
performing and then ads that have
reported a 500 percent growth in views
of the channel's
other videos so basically you can see
growth in views
just by advertising on youtube so let's
get in now to
what are the types of ads you can run
on youtube so we discussed all the
benefits of youtube we can go on for
another two or three hours
because there are plenty of benefits but
i think you get the point of
you know youtube being a place where you
can grow measure
and reach a custom audience so you're
already sold on youtube
now let's talk about those types of ads
you want to run on youtube so depending
on what goal you want to achieve with
your ads there are
different types of ad formats available
on youtube
so our first set of ads evolve around
building brand awareness and ad recalls
so
if you're in the business of promoting
your
product or your brand or your service
then
these are the type of ads you want to
run on youtube building brand awareness
and ad recalls because what it does
is it's really going to get your ad out
there in front of
thousands and millions of people lots of
eyeballs
lots of impressions impressions are the
number of times your ad was seen
so ads centered around brand awareness
are really ads that are going to put you
out there in front of a large number of
people
with the goal of potentially attracting
new customers and ensuring your brand is
on top of their mind
so top of funnel brand awareness is
always introducing the brand
getting people familiar with the brand
and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand
and service and product so that's the
whole idea behind
the ads we're going to introduce behind
the goal building brand awareness and ad
recalls
so let's take a look at what those are
so we can build brand awareness and add
recalls
so we call these these types of ads
trueview for reach
okay so we say trueview meaning our ads
going to appear
in front of a video and we want to make
sure that that adds in front of a lot of
people
so skippable ads that will enable your
brand to reach as many people in your
target audience as possible at the most
efficient price so the whole idea is
we're trying to build brand awareness
then we could set it up on youtube so
that our ad
appears before other videos and that's
going to ensure that our ad
is going to show up in a lot of places
based on the audience we target and if
we can get our ad
in front of a lot of people a lot of
targeted people
at an efficient price then how can you
say no to that
so these ads are skippable have an open
video length and their bidding is based
on
cost per 1000 impressions so cost per
1000 impressions
cpm means that you're paying youtube
for every 1000 people that
looked at your ad okay so that's what
cost per 1000 impressions or cpm means
that you're paying youtube not when
somebody clicks on
your ad but when 1 000 impressions
occurring an impression
is when somebody looks at your ad and so
that's what you're going to be paying
youtube you're going to be paying
them for 1 000 views or impressions
basically okay so the ads are skippable
but they have an open video length and
it's based on eyeballs so that's the
whole
goal there when it comes to brand
awareness you want to go with a cpm
model that ensures you're getting your
ads
in front of lots of people to accumulate
impressions and pay by impressions so
this is what the ad looks like
and now we're going to talk about the
type 2
ad that you can run on youtube and we
call these bumper ads
so they're non-skippable ads with which
you can share your brand's message in
six seconds to drive reach and impact so
we've all seen these videos before
and i'm going to share an example with
you here when you're on youtube
you really can't get to that video that
you really want to watch
until you watch a few seconds of that
video ad
and so that's what these bumper ads are
they allow you to
really make sure that your ad is in
front of that target audience still
it's still paid by impressions but
you know that your ad is going to run
for a few seconds
and the idea behind that is really you
want to get your message out there
and it really does help to drive reach
and impact and so let's take an exam
look at an example on youtube of what a
bumper ad looks like
so here's an example of a bumper ad on
youtube
again it's only six seconds but this
example
is pretty popular on youtube it's uh
been viewed a lot
and we're just gonna take a quick look
at this video here this video has six
seconds
but the whole point is to really look at
the ads purpose
and so if we hit play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long
it appears in in front of other videos
as an advertisement and the whole point
of these bumper ads is really
you have to get your message out there
quickly
because the video is going to start and
you want to really make sure that your
message is being delivered
and you want to keep in this case maybe
keep users guessing as to what it is
and so this is why it's a highly
effective ad you know you got a diver
jumping off a diving board into a pool
that
is basically drying up over a period of
time and so
for curiosity the old saying is
curiosity kills the cat
a lot of people are probably going to
click on that ad to figure out
what is the subject what are we all
talking about here and
really the point of the the video was to
bring awareness about global warming
but that's it that's a six second bumper
ad example
and you really if you're gonna run
bumper ads
you to make sure that you get your
message out there so it has to have
really high impact okay so again they're
non-skippable
they have to be of six seconds and their
bidding is based on again
cost point thousand impressions so it
gives you a
chance to get that ad out there in front
of a lot of people again you're paying
on a cpm model you're paying google for
every 1000 impression okay so
that's could be 1 000 different eyeballs
looking at that ad so if it's high
impact
you know if it's non-skippable then
chances are you can get
you know some clicks some some eyeballs
over to your youtube channel
or to your landing page on your website
so let's take a look at this one from
alaska airlines
better yet let's take a look at this
example from airbnb
i found it to be a little bit more
impactful than the alaska air one so
let's take a look at this example
actually
so we went on vacation with a tow dipper
okay so high impact ad great ad by
airbnb really impactful we went on
vacation
kids playing you have your logo on the
bottom right
corner of the video and you know it gets
people excited about travel so
similar to the alaska airlines which we
didn't look at this one is just as good
high impactful you know getting people
to
you know react within six seconds isn't
exactly a very easy thing to do so
you gotta make sure these videos really
resonate within the time frame that you
have
so let's take a look at type three here
so we're talking about reservation of 15
to 20
seconds so these particular ads can span
up to 20 seconds to increase reach and
make a lasting impression so unlike the
bumper ads which are
six seconds long these reservation ads
tend to run
a few seconds longer up to 20 seconds
okay so
they're also non-skippable and like i
said can be up to 20 seconds
embedding is based on a fixed cpm
and what do we mean by fixed cpm well if
you're bidding on a regular
cpm model meaning that you're paying
google
for every 1 000 impressions that number
could be variable
what you pay google in this case the
fixed cpm
is fixed at a certain rate it could be
you know ten dollars for every 1 000
impressions
20 it really depends on where you're
advertising and who else is advertising
so let's take a look at some examples of
a reservation
ad on youtube up to 15 to 20 seconds
long
so here is an example of a
15 second ad you know also called a true
view ad
so you can see this ad is going to run
for about 15 seconds
before the video actually plays it's
non-skippable
and so let's just play this ad a pitcher
who can paint the corners is known as a
red brand at gmc we get that
everyone loves
this is gmc okay so you can see the ad
itself
uh ran a little bit longer than your
traditional
or your six second non-skippable version
and
the 15 second you know allows you to get
you know more the message out there
still high impactful but allows us to
get the message out there
um with a little bit longer of a video
and that's non-skippable so
it's so going to run for its entirety up
to 15-20 seconds
before the video actually starts playing
so
let's now turn our attention to the
fourth type
of ad you can run on youtube and that
four type is an outstream video ad and
so these ads
are going to reach users wherever
they're watching regardless
of the site or application it's the
whole point of the out stream we want to
be able to get our ads out there
regardless of the site or application
okay so
these ads are also non-skippable and
they can be
15 to 20 seconds long and their bidding
is based on
viewable cost per 1000 impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable costs
per 1000 impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per
1000 impressions is basically if you're
paying
for ad impressions measured as viewable
you you can use this model and basically
what that means that an ad is
counted as viewable when fifty percent
of your ad
shows on screen for one second or longer
or plays continuously for two seconds or
longer so
there's some criteria about the viewable
but you're definitely paying for
impressions
you're just paying when those
impressions showcase the ad
50 or longer or for one second or longer
for
you know other type of video ads or it
plays continuously for two seconds or
longer for video ads
so if it plays in short if it plays for
longer than two seconds
then you're going to pay for that
impression and so that's going to count
as an impression
and that's viewable for 1000 impressions
so
if you get your basically your ad to
show
for two seconds or longer then then
that's going to count as an impression
so for example with the viewable cpm
for example if you bid on 1 000 viewable
impressions
and you pay for impressions that are
measured as viewable an ad is counted as
viewable
again when 50 of your ad shows on the
screen for one second or longer
for display ads and two seconds or
longer for video ads so
uh so that's basically what it's about
so really the key
number here with viewable cpm is two
seconds or longer
that's the difference between regular
1000 impressions cpm
and viewable 1000 impressions vcpm
so let's talk about the next type of ad
format you can run on youtube and the
next one is masted and so masthead is
unique
in that basically they only run for 24
hours
okay so and they run on youtube's home
page
so you can imagine the amount of reach
that you can have
by advertising on youtube's home page so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on
multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of youtube's home page so
they're fixed cost per day pricing
involved and so
the best thing to do is to contact
youtube if you're interested
in advertising on youtube's homepage so
that's the masthead advertising and
basically these ads are non-skippable
they have an
open length and again their bidding is
based
on fixed price per day so here's an
example
of what the masthead looks like on the
homepage so you can see here this is
that gmc
ad okay you can see that they have a
video
supported with a banner and you know
call to action out there
and so what youtube is actually
experimenting with
are you know different ways for
advertisers to buy masted ads
okay so it's you know these ads are very
prominent
so it's it's basically youtube is now
offering the option
uh to buy masthead ads on a cost
per 1000 impression basis so they're
playing around with that
cost format so just keep in mind that
this is a recent change by youtube so
traditionally it's cost per day but now
they're
actually offering the option for
advertisers to buy a mouse that ad
on a cpm basis so just keep that in mind
you do
you do have the option here so at the
end of the day if you're interested in
maths ads and having your ads
show up on youtube's home page for 24
hours
i would still contact google and ask
them about hey
i want to pay cosport 1 000 impressions
so
youtube is actually offering up that
option on pricing model so the second
set of ads
we're going to focus in on are centered
around
this strategy of growth consideration
and interest and the whole idea behind
growth consideration and interest is
really we want to get
our ads in front of people who could be
potential customers but we want to
influence them
okay we want to influence them at a
point in time when they
when we think they're going to be most
receptive to our message so that really
means getting our ad out
in front of the right audience at the
right time because the message we put
out there
is going to be centered around you know
getting them
to not only take notice of our brand but
potentially take action so it's moving
our audience a little further down that
funnel so really
growth consideration and interest it's
all about
placing your ad your message in front of
that potential customer
when you think they're going to be most
receptive
to the messaging you're putting out so
that's what growth consideration and
interest is
so let's go back and look at let's talk
a little bit more about those trueview
ads so
trueview ads are one of the most popular
ways of advertising
on youtube so if you're interested
in you know getting growth getting leads
getting conversions you might want to
think about some trueview ads because
basically these ads can run before
during or after
videos on youtube or you can run them on
video partner sites and applications
again if you're interested
in driving not just brand awareness but
you know clicks to your site so if
you're interested in driving
impact for your brand of products you
might want to focus on the trueview
and stream ads again these are the
traditional ads you've probably
seen before on youtube that run before
during or after
a video and these ads are skippable so
you're likely to have seen the skip
call to action button they have an open
video length and their bidding is based
on cost per view so you're paying
when somebody views your ad and so what
what's
what does that mean cost per view well
let's break that down
cost for review bidding is the default
way to
set the amount you'll pay for a trueview
video ad
so when are you actually paying well
you're paying
when somebody views your video and but
there's a threshold here so
a view is counted on youtube when
someone watches
30 at least 30 seconds of your video ad
or
if it's shorter than 30 seconds and
let's just say it's 20 seconds
then that's going to be considered a
view so 30 seconds is the number here
you need to be concerned about
when you're running a cost per view
model so if you have a video that's one
minute long and they watch 30 seconds
it's considered a view and that's what
you're going to pay you're going to pay
cost per view so that's what the cost
per view model is
and that's the really the default model
with trueview
ads whether that be before the video
during the video or after the video
it's it's cost per view so let's talk
about the other
type of trueview ad and that's the true
view discovery
and so basically what trueview discovery
is is your ads are placed in youtube
search results next to related videos or
on the youtube homepage so you're
getting your ad
discovered more or less you know
throughout youtube
and including the youtube home page so
here's an example of what that looks for
looks like and so let's jump over to
youtube and take a look at that
so if i do type in let's just say
surfing
i may scroll down and i may see some ads
i may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have
ad next to it and so that's
when you know your ad is being
discovered
on youtube and so here in this example
we don't see any ads showing up here so
remember
those trueview discovery ads are going
to have
something with the ad next to them that
way you know it's an advertisement
uh and they're going to be found in the
search results um
on youtube's home page or any page where
you're actually
searching okay third set of ad types
center around driving action and so the
whole point of driving action
is getting that potential customer
to actually take action on the ad that
they see
so in the case of videos we're gonna
have some call to action
stronger call to action to get these
folks over to the website
to purchase or download or you know sign
up for a newsletter
or do something you want them to do
in terms of your business model so if
your business model is selling a product
then the whole point of driving action
on your ad is getting them to buy your
product we want so the whole point of
driving action is making it easier for
customers to take
meaningful actions that you can measure
so the ads we're going to introduce
are centered around getting potential
customers to take action
okay so that's what driving action is
further down the funnel and getting
folks to react to your ad so that they
can take the action that's aligned
with your business talking about
trueview ads now
and so again these ads discovery can
show up
on search results on youtube's home page
uh you have your traditional
in-stream trueview ads where they show
up before
during or after and then here you have
trueview for action
and so these trueview for action ads are
video ads to drive
any action that's important to your
business so again it goes back to that
marketing strategy so the ads we looked
at on early on
were about impressions so a lot of the
cost models for
a lot of the ad types were cost per 1000
impression
and notice now that you know it's it's
now cost per view for trueview ads
and you want to be on a different model
when your marketing strategy
is more aligned with getting people to
take action that's important to your
business for example shopping or buying
something or getting a quote or
or downloading something so if that's
your marketing goal you want to go with
a true view for action
if that's what's important your business
because these ads
are intended to get users to interact
with a clickable button that leads to
your site so that's the whole
idea behind trueview for action type ads
okay so these are skippable they have an
open video length and their bidding
is based on cost per acquisition so
cpa different cost models so let's now
talk about what cpa is so the cost per
acquisition model
is in this case since we're trying to
drive action
we're going to pay when somebody
actually takes that action
so if somebody actually does shop and
they spend twenty dollars
then basically you're gonna pay for that
acquisition
so basically if it's to download
something whatever it costs for you to
get that person over and they actually
download
that's what you're going to pay so cost
per acquisition
is really a model based on action so
when somebody actually performs that
action that's when you're actually going
to pay
google so that's what cpa is and that's
what
the youtube trueview for action ads are
all about
trying to drive action so let's talk
about the universal app
campaign for video and so
this is all about driving action as well
so these ads promote
your app on youtube so where your ads
are more likely to be clicked
and your app downloaded so again
targeting an audience
and really it's about you know getting
people to
look at your application your mobile app
so that's what these ads are all about
they're about promoting
your mobile app on youtube okay so these
ads are skippable
okay they have an open video length okay
meaning you can make them as long as you
want
and again their bidding is cost per
acquisition
but you also have some additional models
as well so we already talked about what
cost per acquisition is because
this is a actionable based ad
so we want people to do something like
download our app
but you also have another cost model
here cost per install
and you only pay when that person who
watches or sees that ad
clicks on it and actually does install
the app
okay you also have another model that
you can apply here and that's the return
on ad spend and the return on ad spend
basically
is you're asking google hey
i want to make sure that if i'm going to
run this type of ad
i'm getting my return on investment
meaning if i spend 100
am i getting a hundred and one dollars
back so
that's the return on ad spend that's a
cost per install and a cost per
acquisition so you have three models
here
for the universal app campaign about
some important metric
uh for youtube so we thrown around a lot
of different cost models when we talked
about the different types of advertising
you can do on youtube
and so with that there's a lot of
metrics
so let's go through some of these
metrics here you have views
clicks your view rate so you have all
these different types of metrics and
for some of you it could be confusing so
what do i need to look like
look at what i need to measure so it
really does come down to
you know what's important to your
business that's always first and
foremost
but here we listed some of the most
common metrics
available to you with youtube okay so
let's go through
some of these and basically a view is
just it shows the number of times
people watched or engaged with your
video ad so a view rate
is basically the number of views or
engagement your ad receives
and the number times your ad is shown
okay so divided by the number of times
your ad was shown
into the number of engagements so if
your ad was shown a hundred times
and you had one like or one click for
example
then that would be one percent so
average cost per view
is the average amount you pay whenever
your watch is
30 seconds of your video so remember
when you're on a cost per view model
remember 30 seconds is the magic number
so if your video is only 25 seconds
then remember that's going to be the
view so it's got to be minimum
or maximum 30 seconds if your video is
under 30 seconds
it's 25 seconds or 20 as an example then
it's still going to count as a view
if it's a minute and somebody watched at
least 30 seconds of it
then that's going to count as a view so
just keep in mind 30 seconds
is the magic number here for the view so
if somebody watches
at least 30 seconds of your video or
engages with your video
that would be a cost per view so that's
the average amount you're gonna pay
and watch time is basically it measure
the total amount
of time people watched your video ads
shown in seconds
okay so it's the total amount of time so
it gives you an idea of how many minutes
total your video is run
so let's focus on clicks so clicks is a
common metric across the board
it shows the number of times people
actually clicked on your video not to be
confused the view
so views the number of times your video
was actually watched a click
is something also measurable and it's
when somebody actually clicked on it so
it's an indicator for how well your ads
are doing
with those who see it and so you know we
want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type
video ads if we're running those action
type ads or universal app ads
we're gonna want people to take action
okay if you're running ads just for
impressions that's one thing so
clicks is an important metric depending
on the type of video ad you're running
so click to rate is the number of clicks
you receive
from your ad divided by the number of
times the ad was shown
so my ad was shown 100 times and i
received one click then that's
one percent click-through rate so let's
talk about engagement
and engagement is the number of clicks
on interactive elements
such as icons in your video ad okay so
that's
what an engagement is here the number of
clicks on interactive elements
and then if we look at engagement rate
then any clicks on an interactive
element
that we receive is going to be divided
by the number of times
the ad was shown so that's why we have
engagement rate as well
so we want people to engage with our
video is there something that
they're doing on the video if so then
what's the rate at which they're
engaging
earned views so that's a number of
viewers who have seen
subsequent videos on your channel or
watch pages
after seeing your ads so watch pages or
videos on your channel
if you've seen those after seeing your
ad then that's going to be
called an earned view so somebody seen
your ad and was impacted by what they
saw
if we look back at the examples we've
shown earlier on with the global warming
or the gmc or the airbnb ads
you know if i saw those ads and i said
man that's really a cool ad or that's
really a good message
i'm going to go over to that that watch
page or i'm going to go over to that
channel
and see what other videos they have when
you do that that's an earned view
and then if you can get an earned view
you're probably going to get
an earned subscriber because it's the
number of viewers who subscribe to your
channel
after seeing your ad so again going back
to any of the ads that you've ever seen
if you've ever gone over to their
channel and then subscribed to the
channel
that's an earned subscriber so your
video ad is doing
something for you it's in this case it's
getting you a subscriber so let's talk
about how to create a youtube ad
so this is going to require some access
to google ads and we'll go over that in
a few minutes here but first we need to
think about setting up a campaign and
setting up a campaign goal okay
what's the goal of our campaign so we
get eyeballs
you know we want to pay costs for 1000
impressions or we want to run some
actionable type ads to get people over
to our website
so that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad
so we want to be able to create a video
out here that is going to show
on youtube and to our target audience so
or whether it be a bumper ad that's only
gonna be six seconds long
we need to be able to figure out what
type of ad we want to run
so here i am in google ads if we're
going to run a
campaign on youtube we need to make sure
that we're choosing a display campaign
and so remember the first step is you
know setting up that campaign setting up
that campaign goal
so we're going to go ahead and select a
new campaign here
we're going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign
so if we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach
that's certainly fine if it's all about
sales or if it's all about leads
then you know the type of video run is
going to be a little bit different
so if we select brand awareness and
reach okay here we're going to select
the campaign type
and so if we select video basically
what we're doing is we're going to tell
google we want
to go ahead and set up some video ads
on youtube and so here you can see the
different types
of video ads we discussed today
you know we got your bumper ads you got
your skippable in-stream
non-skippable so the difference being
that
if it's non-skippable somebody has to
watch the entirety
up to 15 seconds okay so we have our out
stream
which is basically our viewable cpm
model
so we're gonna go ahead and you know
check one of these types of campaign
types or ad types
so we're going to click continue and
then once we do that you know we're
going to get
prompted to you know move forward with
selecting our ad so you can see here
after i set up my campaign
now i'm just going to go through some of
the settings for my ad
and i'm going to give it a campaign name
a budget
okay when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're going to focus
on cost
per 1000 impressions and then here's the
network
so this is an important selection here
so we're dealing with youtube videos
so we also have the option to select
video partners on the display
network so that means that if you want
your video to show
on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on youtube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available
on search results so i'm going to stick
with the video partners
okay youtube videos and here we can get
into some other specifics like
language country the type of inventory
so here you can see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what google recommends
we want to show our ads on content
that's appropriate for most ads
okay so we can go expanded or limited so
we're going with the recommended here
okay and then when we go down we're
gonna have an ad group
so when you create an a campaign you can
have an ad group so
with an ad group that means that we can
have a more or less a video
in every ad group we have but we have to
have at least one ad group so
we're gonna go ahead and set up you know
this ad group here
and here's where it gets interesting and
important because
here is where we can start targeting our
audience so here we got demographics
okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income
okay we can focus in on audiences if we
want to so we can
we can choose a specific audience that
we've set up we can get some ideas or
browse specific audiences
we could also choose a specific
placement so
here you have youtube videos or we can
go with youtube specific channels
okay or we can even be on apps okay we
have to set a bid
for our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us
to add our video ad and so remember
we're in this example we're going to
bumper ads so we're looking at about six
seconds
and once we do that then that's pretty
much the campaign
but i just want to stress here that when
you're setting it up
ahead of time you want to make sure you
identify what the campaign goal is
and then that's going to align with the
type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to
where you want that ad to be and who
you're targeting
so it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so
because you want your video to show in
front of the right audience on the right
placement so let's talk about
how you can optimize your youtube ads so
once you get your campaign set up once
you select your channel or
the type of videos where you want your
ad to be
and you select your target audience and
you're off and running with your video
ad
well we're going to give you some tips
here that you can focus on for
optimizing those ads
and so going back to what i was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully define your metrics and goals
okay so
that's step one so when you're setting
up the campaign remember you have that
option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign
that can be brand awareness it could be
a sale
it could be a lead so to me that's the
you know a very
critical step one so you want to make
sure you align your goal with your video
and then the second
is track low performing ad placements so
if we just ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want
then it's up to us then to go through
and
choose the ad placements and remove them
okay so let me show you an example of
what that means
so if i'm back in google i'm going to go
to my campaign
and i'm going to select placements and
here i can see
placements but then i'm going to select
where my ads show
and so this is important you want to be
able to scan the list of placements
where the ad was shown so if you don't
like one of the placements on youtube
you can always select it edit it and
exclude it from the campaign or advert
so that's really the key
is you want to be able to manage your
placements properly
and when we say low performing ad
placements
we mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get
sales or leads if you're that placement
is not converting sales or leads then
you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within
the google ads platform and then you
know you can also use a
custom thumbnail image in your ad as
well
it's always helpful in terms of
optimization so a couple of other
pointers here to help you optimize okay
you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta
so again depending on the ad type you
know if it's a true view ad
20 seconds long you want to have a call
to action you want to
maybe even have your domain name at the
end of the video so at least somebody
knows where to go
so you always want to have a call to
action with your video ad
you want to use negative targeting
specify who gets to see your ad and who
doesn't okay
so that goes back to your settings so
you can pick and choose
who your target audience is you can pick
and choose who you don't want your
audience to be
as an other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive
so that way people can actually see or
read what the ad is all about
just to make it a bit more interactive
okay you can always perform
a b testing on your ads so if you have
one ad
version you can create another one just
to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always
a positive okay so if you're paying too
much
maybe think about reducing your bids so
if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids
at the ad group level so reduce bids in
areas where you see lower performance so
in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to
re-engage with customers so if somebody
views your ads
and doesn't take action you can always
retarget that person uh
to show your ad another even another ad
format it could be text ads or display
ads but if somebody
looked at your video and they didn't
take the action you preferred them to
take
then you can always retarget them with
another ad
so that's a good way to optimize okay so
we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find
relevant okay that really you want to
make sure that your ad
is you know is with the end viewer you
don't want to put out
an ad that isn't going to give somebody
you know a good feeling after they've
watched it okay
so you want to make sure viewers find
the content relevant so
if they don't find it relevant then that
means your engagement rate
and your engagement is probably going to
be low so you want to take a look at
those
metrics that we viewed earlier
engagement rate engagement and if
they're low
then you probably need to look at the
content of the ad so try to make sure
your ad conveys your brand's message
in the first six seconds so that's why
bumper ads to me are so critical
because you got to get the entirety of
the ad and make it
impactful and so with any ad you run any
video ad you're on you really want to
make sure that that message is conveyed
at the very beginning early as possible
otherwise
you know people are going to be turned
off or not engaged and just going to go
ahead and skip it anyway
so you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include
visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers
okay meaning music or other cool visuals
okay so again you want to be able to
play around and test different ads
and you want to be able to you know
measure the ad performance based on the
metrics we discussed i mean
click-through rate
engagement rate all of those are
indicators
whether the ad is of good quality or not
with the end user
and when i say good quality i mean do
they find it engaging
do they find it interesting if so
they're going to click and if you don't
have good click-through rates for good
engagement rates then you definitely
want to try
doing something different to the ad like
adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user
so go ahead and test some of those out
with a b testing because you have
nothing to lose
but higher or lower engagement rates or
lower click-through rates so
you want to be able to improve those
metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help
lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018
super dry if you're not familiar with
the brand they're you know centered
some asian markets european markets and
they
focus in on clothing uh all different
styles
and sizes and genders from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so their global
brand
they really wanted to take a different
approach here and their approach was
they wanted to focus in on sales they
want to see if video can help
lift them with sales and so
what they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here
was on jackets and jackets to specific
ages
across the board all genders and
interests
and so what they did was they wanted
once take advantage of all the different
ad types
that youtube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here
so if we go to youtube and let's just
take a look at this one
minute ad here 53 second ad buy super
dry
i'm ready now super jam paigey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving
the jacket you're waiting the jacket
you're pulling
the jacket your play pal and posing
this is the jacket the jacket that will
get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see
that you know it was it had some
particular goals there
and so super dry is pretty well known so
it probably
wasn't built around brand awareness per
se
it was probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video
it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds
so it was definitely a true view
probably take action
and so whatever ads they actually did
run specifically
they did see a lift and so we kept
pulse on super dry's account and these
videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so
cool video ran for 53 seconds not a long
time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
a very broad audience of gender uh some
younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million
but the more important thing is because
these videos were to drive action
and so they were able to see a four to
one ratio
on return on investment and as a result
these jackets
saw a 138 increase in brand lip i mean
the jacket ad
so it was a pretty successful campaign
see as well
choreographed good audio good video just
well professionally done
and they probably were able to now get a
few
more loyal customers under their belt
because
of this ad alone so that's the power of
video okay so
you're able to know who your target
audience is you can go out and target
them with a cool video
and given that youtube is vast then
you can really take advantage of a lot
of their ads so what they probably did
again was there's trueview
in-stream ads with a cost per view
through a skippable video ad format and
they they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option
on youtube so they took advantage of all
youtube had to offer
in terms of who they were trying to
target the length of the ad
and given that their product or selling
a product or promoting a product
they will take advantage of the trueview
shoppable ad format which basically
lists your products
alongside the actual video ad and so
this is just a good case study you super
dry
we'll probably do this again based on
the numbers
that they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of youtube getting out
in front of your audience
with a really good video ad targeting an
audience
taking advantage of different formats
hey guys
welcome to this video on youtube ideas
for 2021.
youtube is the social media platform
that needs no introduction
launched back in the year 2005 youtube
was a fresh breath of air for the people
who were slowly becoming aware of the
hype that surrounded the internet
several other platforms like dailymotion
with me and vmo
which admittedly have their own fans
have tried to stand up against the
vehemoth
that is the youtube and failed slowly
but surely marketers began to realize
the enormous potential that youtube
offered
they could add small advertisements like
they do in the cable tv
they could show banner ads and do much
more and all the thanks to the robust
advertisement features that google
already offered
if you're not already sold on why it's
important to advertise on youtube
here are some facts that might change
your mind youtube has more than 2
billion users across the world
a good fraction of that audience could
be shown your product
and could turn from users to customers
next important fact is that
8 out of 10 marketers consider youtube
to be one of the best platforms
to advertise their products and services
followed by that
people watch one billionaires of youtube
per day
as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
youtube
to post content this could be just
videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more
seventy percent of the youtube watch
time comes from mobile
this means that when you create an
advertisement for youtube
you keep the mobile users in your mind
and finally
ninety percent of the people say that
they've discovered new products
or brands on youtube which means that by
posting on youtube your brand awareness
is highly likely to increase
now let's talk about the video ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience
how your business or brand operates a
creatively made video on the
inner workings of your business will
show off a more human side of your brand
and make you more relatable to your
audience it is also guaranteed to get
you loads of views and engagement
here's an example how amazon showcases
the warehousing and distribution aspects
of its products it takes the viewers
into the factories
and involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure
the company works in the way it does
this can help
better connect with your audience here's
an example
a company culture video created by
godaddy the popular domain register
the video talks about how godaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees
it includes interviews of employees
talking about why they enjoy working in
godaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company
and could also catch up the interest
with some potential job seekers
next we have the third idea that is the
marketing team
a brand is nothing without the people
working behind it
and that's where these videos come in
these videos will help shine a light on
the people who create the products
that the audience knows and loves this
helps create a personal connection with
the audience
these individuals can end up becoming
mascots
for your brand here's an example of meet
the team
focusing on olympus group the video goes
into the history of masket maker's brand
and the people that make it a grand
success the lighthearted tone of the
video also greatly helps
with making it more relatable now we
have
number four product showcase or
announcement
a product showcase video aims to show
the features and benefits of the brand's
latest offering to its audience
these short concise videos can inform
the audience about everything they need
to know about the new product or service
a product announcement video on the
other hand can be used to give the
audience
a more detailed look into the product or
service
than the product showcase it can include
comparisons to older versions or
competitors
the aim of such video is to show
customers how the new product works and
why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
apple's iphone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations
of what the product would be like next
at number five
we have event announcements these videos
can build a hype regarding an upcoming
event
it will also give you the opportunity to
engage with your audience and build
their interest
this promo video for the data innovation
summit 2020 hypes up the event posting
the greatest minds in the tech the most
innovative companies
and much more the next video idea we
have at number six
is the explainer videos these videos are
aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service
works these tend to be much more useful
than
wall of text explaining how something
works
they also have an added advantage of
simplifying complex concepts and
features
to your audience for example we have our
own video on digital marketing
we cover a number of different concepts
like seo
social media marketing search engine
marketing
and more on a visual manner making it
more likely to grab the attention of a
viewer
next at number 7 we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights
and knowledge that your users can learn
from
these videos aim to be guides to
information complex concepts
hints tips and tricks relating to your
industry
here we have our own digital marketing
course video as an example
unlike the previous example i mentioned
this video goes into much more detail
regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing
on that note if you guys are interested
in learning about digital marketing
i suggest you start from this video it's
a great one to get started with
now on the next video idea at number
eight we have the product tutorial
a product tutorial video will take your
audience through the various features of
your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail
some additional insights about your
product you can also explain the best
way the product can be used
here's a video of how the meditation app
headspace
explains the app's usage with an
interesting and creative animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine
we have the webinar a webinar thanks to
its nature
provides your brand with loads of
opportunities to interact with your
audience
they are usually very accessible and
easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused
as video content after the session is
complete
here's an example of simply learn's
webinar where we talk to the industry
experts regarding
wide variety of topics while involving
the audience
by having the guest answer the audience
questions
whenever possible next at number 10 we
have
the live streams live streams for an
event
will help build excitement and hype for
the event
it can be advertised on other social
media platforms
to generate some hype as well these
videos can also help you bring up your
product to a larger audience
and at a reduced cost here's an example
of a live stream that constantly keeps a
track of
subscribers increasing for some of the
most popular youtube channels
next at number 11 we have ama or
ask me anything sessions
the ama or ask me anything sessions are
usually
live streams or pre-recorded sessions
that feature questions collected from
the audience although it originated from
reddit
these videos are finding a success on
youtube thanks to the interactivity that
it offers
these sessions can also give your
audience the opportunity to interact
with you
provide suggestions feedback and much
more
here's an example of ama session with
the actor
matt damon where questions covering a
wide variety of topics collected from
reddit
were answered by him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your niche can go a
long way
to grow your audience these sessions are
doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience
get to interact with an industry
stalwart and since this video can be
shared on
your channel as well as theirs you can
expose your channel to a brand new
audience
here's an example of an interview
between marcus brownlee a popular tech
youtuber with bill gates
the interview covers a wide variety of
topics and maintains a pleasant theme
throughout
let's now go to number 13 testimonials
a testimonial video help highlight the
positive feedback from a client or a
customer
they provide social proof and provide a
unique perspective
on your products and services these
videos can greatly help improve people's
trust on your brand
shareability and credibility here's an
example of simply learn's testimonial
video that covers a learner's journey
as he grew in his career thanks to
simply learn certification
a video like this can be greatly
relatable to the audience and even
encourage some of them
to take up a certification let's go to
our next video idea that is the number
14
whiteboard videos a whiteboard video
offers your visually attractive way of
explaining complex concepts
usually this involves a trained experts
breaking through
a complex topic on a whiteboard nowadays
there has also been the trend of digital
whiteboard videos
that work thanks to the visual style and
charisma of the narrator
here's an example of the whiteboard
video simply learn created covering
various concepts of social media
marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have
number 15 competitions competitions or
contest videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved
with your channel these videos enable
you to generate fresh and original
content
with little from your end in an
interesting example
for foldable flight channel users
submitted their ideas for paper
airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions
and saw considerable growth next we have
16 the lists list videos are some of the
most commonly found content on youtube
most users enjoy this type of content
thanks to it
being small easily digestible and
bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from
the best products techniques and much
more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users
with value while further involving them
with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst
in the year 2021 if you are interested
don't forget to check it out
at number 17 we have case studies case
studies talk about
how your product or service have
benefited clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likable
here's a video that analyzes coca-cola's
marketing campaign
and what it made one of the most popular
brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily
for a brand but for individual creators
at number 18
we have tech unboxing these videos
usually involve packages being open for
the first time
while these are fairly common for
technology these videos
have also found success in fashion
apparel these videos enable the users to
experience the products
for the first time sometimes even
helping them decide between rival
products
here's an example of ps5 being unboxed
by marcus brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers
and other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews
with tech reviews you can talk about the
various features of a particular product
what you liked about it what you didn't
its price and other practical
information
and much more here we have an example of
oneplus 8 pro being reviewed in detail
covering its many features
advantages disadvantages and much more
and finally we have number 20 reaction
videos
reaction videos are exactly what the
name says
you giving an emotional reaction to
something like a movie trailer
music video or tv episode these videos
encourage a large amount of engagement
from the audience and make your brand
seem more relatable
here's an example of a reaction video
involving teenagers
reacting to the latest tick-tock videos
these videos usually enable a large
amount of likes comments and shares
today we're gonna talk about how to
increase youtube subscribers
so with youtube it's all about
subscribers
the number of subscribers you have on
youtube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so
gaining more subscribers can help you
achieve more view counts on your youtube
videos so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers
and before we begin let's just show you
what we did at simply learn
so if we look at the past 365 days on
our youtube channel you can see we
started here
back in uh if we look back at march 9
2018 we had 208 and you could see just
over the course of the year
it kept creeping up creeping up creeping
up and
creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers
over the last year and what's our secret
well
it's posting videos so you can see we've
posted a number of videos over the
course of the year
and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it
is about posting videos because when you
post videos
you have people who can watch those
videos when you have people watch those
videos you can have engagement and then
when you have engagement you have
shares and people who like it and then
other people will see it so it's kind of
a halo effect so to speak so
getting subscribers it takes a lot more
than just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about
some tips to help you increase those
subscriptions
so let's start out with some of those
tips we're going to start with
creating engagement informative content
so
engaging in informative content that's
where we're going to start talking today
about how to increase subscriptions then
we're going to talk about publishing
videos frequently
so simply learn you can see the past 365
days
we were consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks
so another tip we're going to talk about
is how to optimize your youtube videos
so there's a lot that goes into
optimization but
this is a key key tip to pay attention
to
because when it comes to posting
publishing videos on youtube
you need to align certain things like
keywords and content and metadata so
optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel
so there's some tips and tricks here you
want to do
to optimize your youtube channel
producing high quality videos we're
going to talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today
engage with our audience okay that's
what we want to do we want to engage
with our audience that's a really key
tip we're saving the best for last
promote your videos in different
platforms so
all of these tips we're going to talk
about today so let's get started
and talk about create engaging
informative content so that's the first
place
we want to start okay so create engaging
and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel
we have to create highly engaging and
informative content why because
not our audience is not going to pay
attention and they're not going to watch
the video and then
the engagement's not going to be high
and they're not going to share the video
and they're not going to tell their
friends or like it and so
this is where it all starts you have to
be able to plan
your content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it
so it's engaging and informative so how
do you do that well let's talk about
that so the first thing is you have to
know your audio okay so when you create
a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts
so when you're creating your content
you're creating your content for your
audience you're not creating it for the
entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about
kittens and jokes and you know people
playing games and you know everybody
likes positive things on youtube but you
know when we're talking about a specific
topic
you know we really have to hone in on a
target audience
and so if you know who your audience is
then you can really hone
in on your content okay so that's the
first thing ask yourself
who is your audience and then build your
content around that specific audience
don't build it just for the mass
general population because it's not
going to be engaging and informative so
that's the first place to start then you
want to engage
that audience with relevant content so
if you know your audience and depending
on the topic you want to make sure
that whatever the topic is the content
matches the topic
don't veer off course if you veer off
course you're not going to engage your
viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason
the reason is the topic okay so if
they're your target audience and they
want to watch the video that's a
specific topic then the content has to
align
so plan your video script so if you know
who your audience is
and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out
so what i normally do is you know have
an outline and then once i have the
outline then i go ahead and create
my slides if i will or my topics points
i want to talk about
and then i write out those points i want
to make sure i get all my points in and
that's what you should be doing you want
to plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all
your relevant points across that's what
makes a video informative okay you want
to ensure
to give maximum information to your
audience so the key here is maximum
information
so you don't want to overload the
audience but then again you want to cut
out information
so you want to make sure that when
you're planning your script
and you're writing the outline that
you're making sure you include
all your points that you want to get
across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to
overdo it so if you feel like it's too
much information it probably is too much
information back off a little use the
information to create another video
so it's all about knowing your audience
so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here
okay just like at the beginning of the
session i showed you an example of
simply learned subscribers over the past
365 days
and so that's what we want to do we want
to be clear but use examples to
punctuate the content or the point we're
trying to get across
so we want to include sources from high
quality sites
so if you're going to use examples make
sure they're from
relevant high quality sites and what i
mean high quality
meaning does your audience know who that
source is or that site
if it's really specific and your
audience may not know then it's probably
not high quality so just keep that in
mind always play
to your audience so you want to start
your video with an interesting hook
so again i go back to this example if
you're still
watching this then the hook worked we
showed you our subscriptions
we showed you how we grew over the
course of a year
you could see our growth and part of it
was posting a lot of videos with
relevant and informative content and so
you see how we did it so you're paying
attention you want to know how to do it
and so
part of what we did is exactly what i'm
telling you now
we know who our audience is we plan out
our scripts we use good examples
and we start our videos with interesting
hooks now when we do our videos
we also create original content so that
goes back to planning your script
okay you always want to you know come
across
as original and informative when you do
that you're going to be engaging but if
you're leveraging somebody else's
content
then the engaging part may not resonate
because it's not your content to begin
with
so always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline
you know feel free to change up the
outline so the flow makes sense
add visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images
to me if you can use images in your
videos
and play off the video or the images
then it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content
so visuals help guide and aid in the
points you're trying to make so don't
make it
so text heavy you know accentuate it
balance it with some images
use simple language and crisp sentences
meaning
don't choose jargon don't come across
and talk above your audience you always
want to talk to your audience
and talk in a language that they're
gonna understand so it goes back to
point one if you know who your audience
is
you're talking to them as if they're
right in front of you
and not you're above them or they're
below you you want to talk at them
so add cards and screens and pattern
interrupts to engage your audience and
so
youtube cards are just interactive
panels that slide in and out when a
video is playing so
it encourages interaction by the viewer
okay so you can add up to five
cards which include images text or
clickable links
so feel free to play around with some of
these features that youtube has to offer
to make your content more engaging so
tip two
publish videos frequently so creating
and uploading videos consistently will
help you increase
your youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month
or two months it's likely that that
audience not gonna subscribe to your
channel
so think about youtube videos as a
popular tv program that comes on once a
week
when a new episode comes on based on the
regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps
your users stay engaged so for example
if i go back
to our youtube channel you know what
helped us gain subscribers
was our consistency in publishing videos
you could see
we were consistent publishing a couple
of videos a week every couple of weeks
and so this helps users stay engaged
they know when the video is coming out
they know that simply learn is good
for two three four videos a month and
the great thing about publishing videos
is that when somebody does subscribe to
your channel they're gonna get a
notification
or youtube has an option where they can
get a notification
via email so i subscribe to
simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video
i get an email that says hey google
analytics
youtube channel just published a video
and the great thing is i'm checking my
email and i'm getting this notification
in gmail so guess what i can watch the
video right then and there just by
clicking on the link in the email
i don't even have to go to the channel
but knowing that if you publish
consistently and somebody does get the
email once a week then it's more likely
they're going to engage especially if
the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing
equals more subscriptions so according
to social media examiner
youtube channels that publish videos
more than once a week are performing
much better so
if you can afford to publish more videos
more than once a week the chances of you
gaining subscribers quicker are going to
be greater so keeping a fixed frequency
can help you quickly gain more
subscribers posting videos is like
almost like blogging i always say
start small if you could do one blog
post a month and then once you get in a
routine
then you can ramp up the frequency so
from one blog post you could do two a
month
then four times a month and once a week
or twice a week
same with the youtube videos you want to
get into a rhythm you know start with
once a month
and ramp it up okay then you'll find
that the more you ramp it up the more
subscribers you're gonna get so tip
three
optimize your youtube videos so
optimizing your videos
will help your content rank higher on
youtube so this is a get
must it's not a given it's a must you
must optimize your videos
if you want people to see them of course
if you don't optimize people aren't
going to see them then people aren't
going to engage and then
not subscribe so it's just kind of a
snowball effect so
this is an important tip so i mentioned
it at the beginning when we were going
over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item
that is a must and a given to some
degree
because if you don't optimize your
videos they're just not going to be
found
so you need that audience to watch your
video
so audiences who tend to interact more
with your content
have more chance to subscribe to your
channel but they're not going to
subscribe
if they don't even watch your video so
there is a snowball effect in play here
if we don't optimize your videos so okay
rob what are some of the tips to
optimize your youtube video well let's
go
through some of those tips so to ensure
your videos reaches
the relevant audience on youtube you
need to optimize the title description
in the video tag okay rob what do you
mean by title description and video tag
so let's take a look at that so
when you actually create your youtube
video you're gonna have
an opportunity to put in a title you're
gonna have an
opportunity to put in a description and
you're gonna have an opportunity to add
text
so those are the three key areas
okay so once you put in that what it
looks like on the front end
is this so if i go back to youtube and
here you can see another video that we
did
about a month ago you could see what is
seo so
if that's our topic that's our title uh
or of the content of the video
then the title of the video is going to
be what is seo
and you can see we also added in some
other
content for the title so what is seo and
how does it work
seo tutorial for beginners and then our
brand name so we have some content to
work with for the title
okay and then the description we have a
lot of characters to work with
description so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good
to include this information okay and
then you can see we have tags up here
seo seo tutorial for beginners digital
marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here
on this video to help us rank because if
we don't optimize it we're not going to
rank and so
you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so
we're able to optimize this video and
get found
so that's just an example three of the
things you can do
to help optimize your youtube video so
if you want to watch
more on how to optimize meta tags then
i suggest maybe watching the other video
we did on the subject how to rank
youtube videos
so this goes into more detail about how
to optimize
the title the meta description and the
meta tags
but those are three quick fields or
areas that you can use
to optimize your video so just something
to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
timestamps and links
so what i mean by time stands for
timestamp an audience can choose the
section of the video that they want to
look for
and then links prefer to include
relevant links of your other videos
so those are just some additional tips
to help keep your content engaging
so remember when your content is
engaging then people are going to like
it people are going to share it and
watch it later so
upload a captivating thumbnail okay so
you want to include a thumbnail that's
going to grab people's attention
you want to upload a transcript of the
video so
that goes back to when you're creating
your content
when you write your original content you
want to keep a transcript
of the content of the video so that you
can upload that as well
and then add a start screen and end
screen to your youtube videos
so that way you know when somebody plays
the video they're going to see it
what it looks like up front and then we
finish it they're going to see
an end screen at the end and so you just
don't want to keep it dark and black and
non-descriptive so according to
backlinko
using an exact keyword in your video
title can help you with rankings
so high ranking more views more views
more subscribers
so that's what i've been saying all
along you need to get these videos
optimized so again
use an exact keyword in your video title
so let's go back again to that video i
just showed you a couple minutes ago
what is seo so here
we started out with a question what is
seo that's the name of the title
that's one exact title of the video
that's our exact keyword
okay so what is seo and how does it work
and then seo tutorial for beginners so
what is seo is our exact keyword and
that's part of the video that's the
content
of the video that's in the title and we
use it throughout the description as
well
so using that exact keyword in your
video title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is
your title of the video or the topic of
the video included in the title
so backlinko also mentions that there is
a moderate correlation between a
channel's total subscribers and rankings
and so
for some of you this may be common sense
it's just like organic search if you're
not ranking you're not going to get
traffic on youtube if you're not ranking
you're not going to get eyeballs on your
videos and you're not going to get
subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings
unless you optimize and so again just
for the sake
of simplicity going back focus in on
your title
make sure your title matches the title
of the video itself when you're
publishing your description
use all the amount of content available
to you so you can see it this entire
description has a lot of content
maximize the content and then use tags
using those three fields those three
areas can help you optimize your video
and gain the necessary ranking you need
to get
viewers which will turn into subscribers
so
tip four optimize your youtube channel
so we just talked about optimizing our
videos now we're going to turn our
attention to
our youtube channel so one of the
easiest ways to ask your views to
subscribe to your channel
is really by creating a good not even a
good a great youtube channel trailer
you also want to add channel keywords a
description
and some good artwork and then having
sections and playlists to keep your
videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good youtube channel so let's
talk about some of these these tips here
so we want to give
your audience a preview what your
channel is offering
so this is by hooking your audience with
the trailer so you can create
a trailer to you know just give your
audience an idea of who you are as a
brand
what kind of videos you're going to be
posting and give them a kind of a taste
of what the future videos are going to
be like
okay you can even tell them your release
schedule in the trailer
so you can start out by saying hey hey
guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling
maybe two per month and you know one per
week
you know just being honest and open and
talking into your audience
and get them excited about future videos
that's what the trailer is all about
so you also want to keep it the channel
description
short interesting so in your channel you
want to have a description of what
the channel is all about what kind of
videos you're going to be posting so in
addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use
keywords in our channel descriptions
just like in the videos with
what is seo we included what is seo
in the title we included you know what
is seo in the description
and so we want to be true to what our
channel is
so pick keywords not only include those
keywords in the videos but include them
in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters
of your channel description because
that's what's shown next your channel on
the search results
so for example here you can see we have
a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address
and so you can see those characters
100-150
or what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's
trying to understand hey simply learn
just uploaded this video who is simply
learning
so you want to write short interesting
channel description
so that when somebody's first introduced
to your video
they could see what your brand's all
about so and your description with an
appropriate call to action
so short interesting good call to action
at the end of the video
a good call to action would be hey check
out our next video or check out our
latest video
something that's going to gauge somebody
and get them to
watch one of your videos so you want to
pick interesting channel art so let's
turn our attention to the simply learn
channel page and here you can see we
recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200
000 k subscribers so 200 000
subscribers is a big achievement for
simply learn we went ahead and updated
our channel r
and i'm sure we will reach 500k we'll
update the artwork then too but the
point is you want to keep your channel
art kind of
interesting hip and cool and feel free
to change it out every once in a while
so you have that option in youtube to do
i mean it's
very simple so here you can see simply
learns channel
we go home we got all our videos listed
here we got the about us
you know something very short
interesting about us
here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn so
you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there
put your description in play and create
your first videos
and get them posted up there and
optimize them accordingly okay so
some other tips to go with that channel
art and description
is a profile picture relevant to your
brand so you always want to
maybe put the company logo up there okay
so here you can see we have the company
logo
add accurate relevant channel keywords
so
if we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with
companies and individuals so we're all
about training and
training is one of our keywords so you
can see
that simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning
aws amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics
so make sure that's included in the
channel
description feature the playlist on your
homepage so if we go back to the home
page
we can see here we have our channels so
you can see we have ai machine learning
trending technologies cloud computing
tutorials
dev op tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different
channels so you want to organize your
videos
into different playlists so those
playlists are going to
feature on the home page of your channel
so how you organize the playlist
is totally up to you but i would
certainly create a playlist
for different sections so depending on
your product your services
think about how you want to organize
don't just stick all your videos
in one playlist then optimize the
playlist
titles and descriptions for search
rankings so just like the videos
themselves
just like the channel description you
have an opportunity to optimize the
playlist titles and descriptions so be
very keen on aligning the right keyword
with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials
project management tutorials digital
marketing tutorials
so we're very clear on how we go about
choosing our titles because we want to
optimize those playlist titles okay we
can rearrange our videos in a playlist
so we want to rearrange the videos in a
way that
we're maybe putting the freshest the
most newest
the video that's been published last
first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our
users to see what video has the latest
in that particular playlist
so they're seeing the most recent first
but you can rearrange your videos any
way you want
feel free to play around with it of
course you can also take the video
that's the most popular and put that up
front
so people could see that first vice
versa you could take a video that maybe
hasn't gotten a lot of
views or isn't ranked particularly high
maybe put that video up so you can get
some views
and some shares and likes so how you
rearrange your videos is totally up to
you
just have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video
so for example if i go back to our
youtube page you can see
the top performing videos here you know
for example this one
we got a nice thumbnail here what is
machine learning so if i click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video
a lot of views 250 000 plus views
so have a thumbnail to go along with
that particular video
so according to backlinko youtube seo
ranking factor study discovered
that channel keywords have a small yet
significant correlation with higher
youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing
your channel and you want to include
keywords
start with your description so if i go
back to our channel
if i go back about us make sure your
description
has those relevant keywords in it that's
where it all starts
so in case you have any doubts if you're
not sure about everything we talked
about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to
every comment that gets posted on our
videos
so if you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel
when you say align keywords with the
channel what does that really mean so if
you want some clarity on that
go ahead and drop us a channel if you're
not sure about the trailer video
drop us a comment we're more than happy
to expand upon the explanation of
how to best optimize your channel okay
tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to
get in the habit of producing high
quality videos because
viewers don't prefer to watch videos
that have poor audio and video quality
it's just that simple
you need to know what it takes to
produce high quality videos if you don't
you're just going to discredit you're
not going to come across as relevant you
know i'm going to come across as
qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so
we need to create high quality videos
for the end users so let's talk about
some ways in which you can create
high quality videos and so the first is
to avoid any noise in the background so
you want to have a nice quiet atmosphere
no distractions so people can hear you
clearly
and only you clearly you want to use
good audio recording equipment there's
plenty of options available on the
internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free
it might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option
so you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online
or it could be some software just make
sure that
you're able to produce good high quality
video and audio
so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to
have something similar to an input
volume meter that way you can
see whether your audio is coming across
or not so
if you're not seeing green lights then
your audio is not coming across
if it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good
quality audio you want to create your
videos in 10
80 pixel size okay that's hd and so you
want to have at least minimum 1080. so
anything less than that it's probably
going to come across as not so
good maybe staticky blurry not
professional
not high def so you want to create a
high def video and 1080
is about the minimum you want to go and
then you want to plan your video script
before filming
so it goes back to some of the other
points i made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly
then you want to use good lighting for
video recording so
you don't want to be in a dark place you
want some nice lighting
so your video comes across well lit
people could see you they're not
struggling
to strain their eyes on what it is
you're trying to show and appear because
of poor lighting
again it just comes across as
professional so if you can you know
shoot a high def video
with good audio speaking clearly having
a professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious
and they're going to start to listen and
engage and see the video as good
quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so
use slow motion and jump cuts wisely so
there's some features you could do with
your video
you know using slow motion and jump cuts
are some of the features
you can use to accentuate your points
and then set up a green background for
recording again this is
for you know making sure that the video
part of it comes across in good quality
and stabilize your video recordings with
a tripod
that way you're not moving your video
camera all around
and and again it's coming across as
shaky and poor quality
shoot horizontal videos you don't want
to go vertical
it tends to cut the screen so you want
to stay horizontal so that people can
see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot
using a clip-on lens again a good
feature a good
tip to use use that wider shot okay so
you could do that using a clip-on lens
and then choose good video editing
software i can't state this enough
because
you're putting all this time and effort
into a video you need to be able to edit
it
to cut out you know some of the things
you didn't want to say
or maybe some poor quality or or you
know you just want to have a smooth
professional output for your video and
so you gotta have
good video editing software there's
plenty of options available on the
internet
again i would go with something low cost
but paid usually
free isn't exactly the way you want to
go if you're trying to create a high def
good quality video at the very least
review your work before publishing
i just said it a minute ago i'll say it
again you want to be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video and high def
with good audio horizontal shots
you know nice green background image
nice well lit
it's gonna come across as professional
and if you have a professional
video then people are gonna take you
seriously they're gonna see you as a
professional
and then share or subscribe and like
and then they're gonna watch more videos
and and that's how you
start to build up a reputation as being
a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos
so you want to review your work because
if you don't you put all that effort
into it and then you're going to realize
hey your video is low quality and then
you're going to have to do it all over
again so
follow these tips get a high quality
video and you should be on your way to
ranking in fact
according to backlinko youtube
preferably
ranks hd videos so you got to have that
1080
uh pixel size that way you know your
video is going to come across
crisp and clear and youtube prefers that
tip six
add a subscriber watermark to your
videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on
all your videos the reason why you want
that watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but
normally it's going to be some type of
logo
or brand and a call to action and so how
do you add a watermark to your video
well you log into your youtube account
it's it's pretty simple
at the top right corner you're gonna
select your creator studio icon and then
you're gonna go to channel select
branding
and then add a watermark to your video
so if we look at that on youtube
so here creator studio on the left side
navigation i'm just going to
click channel then i'm going to click
branding and then once you click
branding
you have the ability to add your
watermark
and then you can add it to the entire
video at the end of the video
and specific start time and then just
click update and that's pretty much it
so you want to be able to add this so
that you can
brand your videos with an image and then
add that cta
so this is a good good feature for
youtube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos
by branding and adding that call to
action tip seven
engage with your audience so you want to
be able to interact with your audience
as much as possible
just because the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you
interact with your viewers especially
when you interact with them immediately
there's gratification you know everybody
likes to be responded to
nobody likes to be ignored and so when
somebody is responded to
there's a higher chance that your
viewers are likely to going to become
customers it's just customer service
is how you really want to look at this
okay so when you engage
you're creating a service for your
customers
so here are some tips on how to engage
with your audience so
first is at the end of every video
convey a thank you message to your
viewers you know thank you
for spending the time out of your busy
day to watch this video
you know some of our videos go an hour
plus long
and so when somebody's taking an hour to
watch a video
it's only the least you can do is thank
them
now you can thank them and give them
some information about where to go for
more information
because if they watch the whole video
they're already engaged and they're
probably going to want to learn more
so you always want to follow up to thank
you with where to go for more
information just like our videos always
convey at the end okay you always want
to ask your audience for their feedback
or ideas on the video
so with youtube there's a comment
section and you always want to encourage
comments so comments can be in the form
of feedback
so as you're watching this video feel
free to leave feedback
on other ways to engage with your
audience or some other
tips to increase your subscribers on
youtube so we're always looking for
those ideas we want to keep it engaging
so
somebody may have some other ideas that
we didn't think about
and so we always appreciate that from
our audience so we very much appreciate
the feedback that
our audience gives us so not all the
feedback
is always going to be positive some of
the feedback could be less than positive
or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback
is you want to look at it you want to
read it and you want to react to it you
want to react to it positively
in the form of you know what thank you
for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback
so you don't always want to make the
same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example
and somebody looked at it and gave us
feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again
so you always want to learn from your
mistakes and you want to
turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request
the audience is giving us feedback we
should take that
as positive and sometimes that's
creative sometimes those
ideas for more videos okay you always
want to ask questions to your audience
and reward
excellent commenters so we try to ask
questions in our videos
and when users respond with their answer
if there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them
in the form of say some type of gift
card or gift certificate or promotion
or or something there's always some way
to incentivize somebody
who provides excellent feedback you can
always give emoji hearts
there's so many emojis out there that
you can use emojis just to engage with
your audience based on the feedback that
they're giving
the point is if your audience is taking
the time to give feedback
you always want to respond to it and you
want to respond to a positive so emojis
tend to have a positive connotation to
them
and so responding with an emoji
especially to a favorite comment goes a
long way
so you can reward your community both on
and off youtube for their engagement and
support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways
many ways not necessarily monetarily but
by recognition
you could do promotions you could do
something fun there's always ways to
reward
and prefer to host live streams and
interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them
other platforms like facebook have them
instagram
so you can certainly reach out to your
audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience
right there in the flesh so when you can
have an opportunity to talk to your
audience and engage with them that's
always going to work
because they can see personality they
can see what you're all about
and there's two-way conversation and so
that will lend to
more of a you know relationship so to
speak with your audience
so you want to create videos for
subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel
dedicates a video for them so you know
take the time out
to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most
likely going to engage with you okay
they're your loyal fan base so if you
create something for them that's a form
of a reward
so you can captivate your viewers by
uploading interesting youtube stories
as well you can also hear from your
audience and get their videos
and use their videos and upload them to
your channel so
according to backlinko video comments
have a very strong correlation with
ranking so
as you create a video feel free to talk
to your audience and ask them
hey if you have any comments feel free
to put them in the comment section right
below this video
i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see
about rewarding the audience or engaging
with the audience feel free to comment
we'd love to get your suggestions
because if you can engage with the
audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings
but with your subscriber base so
comments are the way to go
solicit comments respond to the comments
reward the comments
tip number eight promote your videos on
different platforms
so promoting your videos on different
platforms has been around for many years
it's a good strategy
once you create your video on youtube
you want people to see it you want to
get it out there
so if you want to increase your youtube
subscribers this is a strategy
you have to perform so let's take a look
at all the ways you can
use and leverage different platforms to
increase your subscribers
so before you do that you want to
research discover how
you can use different platforms so the
first thing you want to do is look at
the platforms you're already using if
you're using
facebook and instagram that's probably a
good place to start but there's other
platforms you can also leverage and
we're going to talk about those
so social media most companies most
individuals are
on in some form or fashion amongst the
most popular like facebook and instagram
so you could start there so with
facebook you can post something
include the link of your youtube video
with facebook
if you're a business you have a business
page you're communicating with your
community
and that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video
you can also do the same on twitter or
instagram or whatever platform you're on
go ahead and post something or tweet
something and include that link to
youtube you can participate in forums
and blog discussions so there's plenty
of forums and blogs out there where you
can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a
blog about machine learning you can
include if you have a video about
machine learning
in the response to that conversation in
this example we've done that on reddit
you can list your video in relevant and
reputable directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can
just go ahead and publish your video on
you can use testimonial link building
okay so somebody can provide a
testimonial include the link
of your video you can opt for influencer
marketing so
if there's somebody that is associated
that likes your brand or product
and has a large following you can ask
them to post a video on your behalf it's
a great way to reach an
audience fairly quickly okay you can
earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example
if you look at this website here test
genics okay there's a
article here about you know certificate
of achievements
okay for aws so if you scroll down we
could see
our video is included here in this
particular web page
so this is a high quality web page okay
that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic
and awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to
your video topic and see if you can
collaborate with them on producing a web
page to include that video you can also
take advantage of email marketing by
adding your youtube link in the email
signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like gmail or yahoo or even hotmail
or outlook is going to have an ability
to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature
you could simply just include a link to
the video or to
your youtube channel it doesn't have to
be do a specific video but it's a way to
get
people to your youtube page or to that
video so
the whole idea is more eyeballs more
potential subscribers
engage your audience by posting your
video links on community pages
so for example you know we're promoting
something here on a community page
and that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free
very little time to do this but it's a
chance for you
to get the video out there and even
generate a backlink you can collaborate
with other youtube channels this is
always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic
on youtube chances are there's probably
somebody else out there doing the same
thing
it doesn't have to be necessarily a
competitor it can be a complimentary
product or service and if you offer that
then go ahead and collaborate with them
and see if you can exchange your videos
on their channel and you can take their
video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always
a question of being posted and if you
have the answer
to that question in the form of your
video then go ahead and post a response
with a link to the video on youtube it's
a great
way to get the video noticed and it's
relevant and natural
okay you can embed videos in your blog
posts or if you're using a platform like
wordpress for example
very easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link
in the blog post i like this option
i think blog posts are always good
because you don't have to be
text heavy with a blog post you want to
create a blog post that's nice and
balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further
and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so
having a video in your blog post always
goes well in my opinion
okay so you could promote other videos
in your end screen for example
at the end of your video you can always
promote something related
like we've done here in this example so
lots of ideas
get your video out there use them an
email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon
you know collaborate with other people
on youtube you know go to core
respond to a question use social media
to your advantage there's
lots of opportunities to get your video
out there the more you can get your
video out there
the more traffic you're gonna get the
more traffic you get to the video the
more subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played
in order to get your video out there but
these are relatively
you know low time consuming ideas to get
your video
some some subscribers so let's turn our
attention to some key takeaways from
today's video
tip one you always want to create
engaging and informative content
so that's where it all starts remember
think about what you want to say
and do before you do it know your
audience that's really the key takeaway
know your audience
tip two publish videos frequently okay
you don't have to start out publishing
three or four a week you know start out
publishing one a month if that's
how it works for you and then once you
build momentum once
you start getting a loyal fan base and
start getting more subscribers
then think about increasing your video
output tip three optimize your youtube
videos
title description tags that's always a
good
place to start you want to work in that
keyword
that's relevant to the topic and work
that into the title
work it into the description and work it
into those tags
tip four you want to optimize your
youtube channel there's lots
of features available okay you want to
start with your description of your
channel
because the description is what shows up
when somebody does a search or sees your
video so
that is key you always want to optimize
your channel as well as your videos
tip 5 we want to produce high quality
videos
remember 1080 on the pixel you know use
good audio video equipment don't
necessarily go free
go with something low cost but make sure
you're using something that's going to
output good audio and video quality
because
people are gonna take you serious tip
six good feature in
youtube under the channel settings okay
in the creator studio
you want to be able to add a subscriber
watermark that way
people know who you are and you can add
that call to action so that they can
scribe to your video
tip seven engage with your audience
comments comments comments
in fact for those watching this video
now if you have any comments on any of
the tips that we provided feel free to
put them in there
we will respond and we will reward and
that's what you want to do with your
audience you want to
engage with your audience to make them
feel like they're
part of the community and part of the
solution and then tip eight
promote your videos and different
platforms there's plenty
of opportunities from social to blog
posts to influencer marketing
to email marketing lots of different
opportunities to get that link
out there the more you can get that link
out there the more traffic you're gonna
drive
the more traffic the more eyeballs are
gonna realize hey this is some good
stuff here i'm gonna subscribe to this
video i'm gonna subscribe
to this channel and i'm gonna wait for
this channel to produce
more videos so these are the tips and
with these key takeaways and these tips
you should be on your way to increasing
your subscriber base
and with that we have come to the end of
this youtube marketing fill course video
for 2021
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below and our team of experts
will be happy to solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning